alors dans les salles du ciné cette
semaine entre autres films je dis bien
entre autres parce qu'on propose
plusieurs films deux films très
intéressant burning qui est un film
coréen qui inscrit d'heure on va dire
sentimentale coréen qui est et qui
faisait partie de la sélection du
dernier festival de cannes qui a été
injustement écarté du palmarès
donc c'est par le réalisateur et poetry
il ya huit ans donc je vous encourage
vivement à venir découvrir ce film en vo
dans nos salles et un autre film une
comédie comme on dirait jeu familial on
va dire de cécilia rouaud avec un
casting assez exceptionnel jean pierre
bacri notamment pierre de la dhr au
chant et cetera photo de famille donc on
reprend cette semaine dans nos salles
c'est une comédie douce-amère une
chronique familiale autour d'une maman
qui va pas bien et qui va finir par
disparaître malheureusement et on voit
les personnages principaux de cette
famille s'entredéchiraient je sais mais
se retrouver et c'est au fil du temps
voilà donc à voir dans nos salles cette
semaine
aussi le cep
[Musique]